our mission here at Ed works is to
provide a new way for people and
machines to interact and then that goes
both ways that's human machine and also
machine human interaction so that we can
actually work together instead of
instead of seeing computers as a hammer
that's just you know a tool sitting
there on the bench we can see computers
as allies that we that we interact with
and work with to solve common problems
and to and to work towards our goals
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started 20 minute leaders is a proud
supporter of makeawish Israel and Tech
to peace and is in proud collaboration
with secret cord Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
[Music]
I'm so happy to have you here Elliot you
know over the last few weeks we've
become friends we're starting a
partnership together you know there's so
many different things that are happening
and and I just love what you do and so I
ask you to come here and to spend this
time with me sharing what Ed works is
about what you're about the the way that
you're thinking through you know the
future of of AI and the human computer
interactions and the different questions
we're asking is really really
interesting and uh and I'm fascinated to
hear your perspectives in these 20 short
minutes so thank you again tell me a
little bit about who you are and where
you come from how did you get into this
space yeah absolutely so my background
is actually in in educational technology
I started at the New York City
Department of Education um when I when I
was there in the early 2000s we were
using some pretty Antiquated um systems
at the time so I ended up doing some
some coding uh built built some new
information systems for the translation
interpretation unit and got really
interested in the uh the data that we
were collecting we were you know we were
out there every single day going to
different schools helping support
non-english language speaking parents
helping them understand the services
that were offered to them by the City by
their schools Etc so we started to
really UND gather data about where
different where different communities
actually lived where people went to
school how they how they lived their
lives um and that led to sort of an
application of some of my longtime
longtime background in sort of math
physics the these sorts of things into
into the social space and I also have a
background in um linguistic anthropology
and sociology so sort of all of that
came together and uh for of this perfect
storm I ended up going and joining a a
fairly small company at the time called
Wireless generation we grew to become
one of the biggest edtech companies in
in the US and um yeah that that the know
the rest is history there amplify is
still around as they're called now the
awesome company um have a lot of friends
there but I left um SE many years ago
now to come here to Edy Works um and to
start growing something sort of of of my
own so to speak so you know Edge works
itself is an old company founded in 2001
but really was very very small I joined
around 9 years ago and we just started
growing and growing and um today we're
you know today we're much much larger
we've been growing about 25%
year-over-year and you can do the you
can do the math on that if you if you'd
like you start with small numbers
exponents don't grow quite as fast um
but our our area really is focused on
human performance and what it means to
understand who people are what they do
and the application of Advanced
Technologies in that space that's
incredible so one of the things that we
we discussed and and I want to get right
into it you know everybody today is
doing is talking about generative AI
this is you know the the the hot kid on
the Block and one of the things that
that as I got to know you over the last
few weeks is some of the remarkable work
you've been doing you know well before
you know this has become entral entral
hype and I think this is probably the
most amazing you know um part of
identifying you know a founder and and
somebody who's who's thinking long term
tell me a little bit about you know how
you got into this space and what were
your thoughts even a few years ago yeah
absolutely so we've been interested in
natural language processing for a long
time there's there there's a claim
that's made in sort of the anth the
Linguistics World um the linguistic
anthropology World in particular and
that's that language is the medium of
communication so most human interaction
happens through language not all of it
there are plenty of other things that we
do but when we are trying to pass on
information learning in in particular so
we're trying to improve ourselves or
describe ourselves we typically use
language to do that and as and as a
result we've been really interested in
language going going way back so we we
started off working in Tech things like
LDA um you know late
and continuous skip grams these are old
old techniques late semantic analysis
but about 5 or six years ago you know
Google had this had this paper attention
is all you need and we saw the potential
in it to actually encode human language
in a way that was a lot richer and
deeper than you could do with things
like semantic analysis or LD or any of
the other techniques that we use so we
jumped on that bandwagon right away um
we we we built we took Bert um early
models like Bert and Elmo worked with
them rebuilt versions of them retrained
versions of them ourselves built all
built our own pipelines did all that
stuff and we've actually used them to
support projects Over The Last 5 Years
ranging from the National Science
Foundation US Department of Defense US
Navy Air Force all of all this stuff um
now obviously in the last 18 months or
so the power of these models has really
gone up a notch um because what I I
would say nobody really expected
honestly was that by increasing the size
you would you would increase the output
of these models as so dramatically we
knew that bigger models would be better
but nobody really foresaw the depth of
connection that would be encoded in
these models as they went from you know
30 million parameters to 300 million to
3 billion to 30 billion 300 billion now
there are rumors of trillion um
parameter models
I will say at this point it's getting a
little silly um we we've reached we no
it is um the way that language models
themselves work they're really
inefficient at encoding the data so
we're getting much better at actually
building them so their size the actual
Peak size is probably starting to
decrease rather than increase finally
yeah but yeah it's been it's been a wild
ride but Elliot what you know you
mentioned bir Elmo attention you know
that all feels like ancient history at
this point yet you you know it really
does you just said those words and I was
like wow yes this was this was the topic
of conversation back then walk me know
take me back to those days when you're
you're you're there with your team and
you realize that a shift is happening
something is happening in the way that
we are experiencing language and you
decided to to to double down on that as
a as a research company but but actually
creating solutions that meet criteria of
Defense organizations and you know
really interesting customers so yeah
we're kind of a weird company I will say
we we started off as a research
organization you're right but our
strength has always been applying that
research to real problems we build
Business Solutions um for big
complicated
organizations part of that honestly is
because the US Department of Defense is
one of the largest funders of
foundational training research they they
do they're one of the biggest training
organizations in the world they are
willing to put their money where their
mouth is and they really care a lot
about understanding the best ways to
learn and the best ways to train um so
that you know there's a sort of a
natural a natural fit there but yeah we
we started working with language models
because the techniques that we'd had
before were mechanistic and unsatisfying
quite honestly they were you know they
grew out of a statistical perspective on
the world um so LSA in which you're in
which you're doing VAR statistical
predictions of your next words you know
even even continuous skip grams bag of
words approaches these all these all
came from a language as a tool view in
which in which language it wasn't
highlighting the human element within
language which is what always interested
us when you're talking about human
performance everything you do is
grounded in trying to understand who
people are what they care about why
they're acting in certain ways and then
based on that what they're what they
might be able to do in the future what
they might want to learn how they might
progress a career all sorts of questions
come out of it the techniques that we
had were able to do things like look at
a look at a look at a course look at
training materials and try to understand
what's did it but they did they did a so
a fairly poor job the language models
came at this came at the the philosophy
of language from a completely different
perspective they really I mean in some
ways is depressing that it works so well
because they really just said we have a
lot of text let's just pour a lot of
text through you can think of it as like
a this is this is sort of how I how I
conceptualize this stuff it's sort of
silly are you fam with pachinko machines
where you you put a coin in at the top
and it sort of bounces around yeah um
some ways that's what language models do
you pour in large chunks of text and you
have layers layer fully connected layers
of models and it just sort of bounces
around and what you get out of it though
is a model that you can't interpret it's
got all of these Dimensions all of these
connections but it's but what it's done
is it's encoded the actual way that we
use language not just statistical
relationships not nothing mechanistic
around the structure of language per se
sure we encod we include part of speech
tokens when we when we in you know put
stuff into these into these models but
the the core idea here is that human
language is flexible it's
multifaceted individual words have many
meanings many contexts senses and and
different dialect ways of applying them
and using them and we should stop being
stubborn and thinking that there's some
meta structure that exists there there
are structures but they are very soft
and language every rule can be broken
the way we speak is not the same as the
way we write there there's just there's
all of this there's all of this that
goes on around it and language models
have a softness about them that allows
them to encode that um and and to jump
forward to today where we are a lot of
our a lot of our philosophy at Edge
Works still comes from this
understanding of how the models
themselves work open Ai and and chat GPT
gbd4 these sorts of things are all the
rage they're very popular but they're
applying language models as as what we
call generative models they use them to
generate in this case text their image
models their Audio models all this but
but the goal is to generate something
that sounds or looks human um and that's
great but from our perspective that
under leverages the deeper sort of
nuance that these models have and so we
actually don't use these models
particularly frequently for Generation
we will at the end of at the end of a
stack but we have but our techniques
tend to involve layering lots of models
together and using them to to actually
act as as World interpretive layers so
to to go back to that sort of linguistic
anthropology thing where we communicate
through language that's how humans in
code experience
there's no reason that we can't do this
you know that we can't use do that at a
at a machine level as well using
language models to understand human
encoded experience so that that's sort
of a bit of the philosophy behind how we
how we think about this incredible so so
take me take me to today and what what
is at works today and what what what are
you doing I mean you're we're now at
this you know inflection point for the
world and and I think that what you're
doing is also very special towards the
next few years so let let let let me
know you know what here yes so we're at
a big transition point to be completely
honest for the last five or six years
we've worked really hard on building a
machine linkage layer that links raw
data streams to Frameworks that describe
people skills Frameworks job Frameworks
learning objectives all of these things
that that people use um around your
resums all all of this all this sort of
human structure and we've done this
using what was the best technology
available and we would use language
models to help us do that linkage to
help us link the data sources to these
Frameworks with the larger models that
we have available now we've had some
recent breakthroughs that that really
lean on the stuff I was just talking
about and allow us
to in some sense sideline the models we
don't have to put those models in the
Forefront instead we can use those as
inputs into a into a into a language
model so we can use those Frameworks as
inputs and instead say hey talk about
yourself be whoever you want to be
interact with this interact with this
device this language model and we can
and we we still have the technology that
allows us to then hook that model into
hard data source in the back end and
create a direct linkage and that's all
very high level so let me give you just
a little quick you know concrete example
of like of what that means um I've been
using this example a bit because this is
this this really happened to me many
years ago my my boss asked me to do a
little bit of analysis of the schools
that we were working in in the kto space
and can you look at the at the inner
city schools and see how they're
performing how students are learning
compared to other other schools other
schools I said sure now our database
didn't have inner city schools that's a
that's a human concept that's not
necessarily a database structure sure so
that took me a long time as an analyst I
had to go sit down come up with a
criteria what is inner city go school by
school build tables build database
structures and quite friendly that sucks
that's a place where as people we have
to translate our world
into really really rigid data
structures the Breakthrough that we've
had at Edge Works what we're able to is
say we don't have to do that anymore um
we're able to use language models
layered together with with a set of
other techniques to allow you to
interact using human language directly
with underlying data so you can say hey
here a question about inner city schools
language models know what inner city
schools are this is something that's
very well understood in human speech now
the understanding of language model has
might not be this exactly what I want I
might have to tweak things at the end
but I'm able to just communicate I can
actually just go to go to the system
that we're that we're setting up this is
using our enlightened series of models
and I I so I can go to a light and I can
say hey pull pull data that looks pull
data that looks like what would our
company look like if all of our
contracts in the pipeline came through
but a couple of things a couple of
things fell through and I can be I can
be that soft about it I don't I no
longer have to translate what I want to
know into a specific data structure and
then give that to the machine I can let
my devices actually handle that
translation which is it it's it's so
transformative it's hard to describe
because it's just it takes so much
mental load off I don't have to try to
think like a machine anymore I can do my
job as a human being and imagine the
world and interact with the world around
me which is something that people have
always been really good at but over the
last 30 years or so with the explosion
in computing power we' kind of started
teaching ourselves not to do that we've
started teaching ourselves to think in
Google Search terms you know oh I want
to find a good restaurant near me how do
I do that how do I translate what I want
into a search query that will get me
what I want that's a ton of time effort
and labor that we shouldn't have to
spend we should be able to ask our
conflicted
imprecise messy questions we should be
able to do that and let you know and let
our devices try to help us interpret
them let them become Partners in in
working that out and we really can't do
that now so that's that's really the
That's The Cutting Edge of what we're
focused on today at Edge Works
incredible you know one of the last
things that we we got to talk about you
and I was you know this the really this
perception that you know we're looking
at what's happening today we're looking
at language and the mode the human
computer interaction between us and this
you know the sort of this this this
entity that is able to partner with us
and one of the big big Transformations
that are happening is that you know
we're not going to be limited to the
ways in which the modality in which we
communicate it's going to be a there's
going to be a variety of ways and it'll
just be a part part of our life and I
think that you know it sounds to me that
you're very excited about this future
that we're going into I'm super excited
although you know Michael you've asked a
lot about Ed I will say I'm also super
excited about the stuff that you guys
are working on because it's it's so
important for all of this you know I'm
I'm being a just a tad bit disingenuous
I'm presenting all the positives I'm
this is what excites me this is what
we're working on right but there are Bad
actors out there um and there and and
there are organizations and individuals
who are excited about the ability to
rapidly create misleading and you know
misinformation so we're moving into
Uncharted territories you know our
mission here at Ed works is to provide a
new way for people and machines to
interact and then that goes both ways
that's human machine and also machine
human interaction so that we can
actually work together instead of
instead of seeing computers as a hammer
that's just you know a tool sitting
there on the bench we can see computers
as allies that we that we interact with
and work with to solve common problems
and to and to work towards our goals um
but I'm also so grateful for
organizations like yours that are
helping make sure that this is done in a
positive and benign way I I love that
and and the the beautiful thing is that
we get to work together on also solving
the the the the problematic parts so
that we can all enjoy the amazing parts
and and you've been doing amazing work
on that front ALB quiet but but really
with with a lot of effort and a lot of
intelligence and so I'm very excited for
for what's to come between the two of us
and and and I really want to thank you
for this time and for coming on I think
that this conversation needs to be
Revisited H you know in a few years and
we'll look back and we'll say wow you
know this was a you know what a time we
we lived in just like now you're talking
about Bert and Elmo I'm like wow what a
time that was that was no it's true and
I'm looking forward to it as well and
I'm personally looking forward to it so
thank you so much for having me I really
really appreciate it thank
[Music]
you